[Music]
I think open worlds are a very appealing
idea for gamers you're putting these
massive spaces with dozens of places to
visit seemingly endless quest to take on
and the freedom to explore how you want
developers seem to think so as well
because we've been getting an
oversaturation of open world games at
the plate and back during the 360 ps3
era when shooters were the most popular
genre trend started happening where
beloved game series like syndicate were
turned into first-person shooters this
upset a lot of people because what made
syndicate syndicate was gone today we
are seeing something similar with series
like Mirror's Edge and Metal Gear adding
open world while these are completely
changing genres the way syndicate did
metal gear is still about self and
mirrors edge is still about first person
parkour running adding an open world to
a series that never used one will alter
the design of the game sometimes this
works out great with series like far cry
we're adding an open world is the
logical next step to evolve its design
but other times the open world is
unnecessary or worse it removes elements
that make the series interesting and
replaces it with open world design we've
seen dozens of times before a game I
think completely justifies its
transition to open world is the witcher
3 wild hunt the core of the game is
still the same as the previous game you
have your main quest side quests and
master contract only now the space you
are given is significantly larger and
this larger space is used to expand
quest that couldn't be done previously
monster contracts becomes reeling chases
and side missions like a tower full of
mice get their own Island this massive
space also helps make the northern
realms feel like a real place by telling
the story of a country ravaged by war as
you see the effects on both the land and
its people comparatively Mirror's Edge
catalyst open-world the city of glass
feels unrelated to the rest of the game
the main story is a series of levels
that features straightforward pads with
increasing challenge to tester parkour
skills and they all take place in
locations outside of the open world they
don't take advantage of the open space
the city of glass gives and the city is
mostly they're to travel from mission to
Mission traversing the city lacks the
increasing parkour challenge of the
story missions and over the course of
the game you will travel the same paths
over and over making it quite boring the
city is populated with some running
challenges but personally I didn't find
them very interesting rather than
providing an exciting place for me to
explore the city of glass felt more like
an extra step I now needed to take to
get to the parts of the game I actually
wanted to see the good parts of the
original mirrors edge is still here
there's just now an extra barrier to get
some so while the core of mirrors edges
design doesn't really evolve with this
open-world conclusion metal gear solid 5
the Phantom Pain's does it's free form
open-world setting takes metal gears
focus on Claire experimentation and
places you in a true sandbox environment
to play around with how do you approach
a base do you cite from a distance or go
loud up close do you use D horse d dog d
walker quiet or maybe you just
the phantom pain uses this open-world to
allow players as many options as
possible and I think this is all
wonderful however the game suffers some
of the pitfalls at other open world
games have there are over 150 side ops
which is a real overload of missions and
it doesn't help that they start to
repeat in objectives very quickly if you
try and play the game to full completion
it can take you around 90 hours and is
easy to start getting sick of it this is
a far cry from the much tighter pacing
of previous Metal Gear games which would
take around 20 hours for a completionist
run another thing the phantom pain loses
is metal gears traditionally told
bombastic cinematic narrative cutscenes
are kept to a minimal and most of the
story is told through collectible tapes
your will buggiest up the invention all
right but I still don't get it now audio
logs aren't something that only open
world games doom but a lot have adopted
them because it's a great way to double
up on collectibles and narrative it also
allows players to experience the
narrative at their own pace which is
very much in line with open-world
freeform design now I found that they're
just personally wasn't enough narrative
they are compared to the previous games
to feel satisfying on this front and it
is the reason a lot of people play metal
gear but in other ways I'm okay with
this because the phantom pain is a game
that really gives the impression that it
chose to put all of its efforts into the
open world gameplay and that part of the
game really is quite good and then we
have Final Fantasy 15 and you could very
well make the argument that the series
has always been open world ish but in 15
s case it's specifically influenced by a
more Western approach to open world
design in a very unfun all fantasy move
it throws you into its open world within
the first 10 minutes of the game and
then gives you a large amount of freedom
and how you want to explore and I think
it all works quite well cruising the
world in your car is fun and the various
activities you are given like camping
fishing chocobo racing and frog
collecting I'll support the tone and
feeling of a road trip I think the team
makes a great argument for open-world
design in a final fantasy game where
fall short is how the narrative feels
disconnected from the open world itself
the major plots and events which include
an entire kingdom being overthrown don't
actually impact the inhabitants of the
world who still go about their day like
nothing happened the disconnect is
worsened when major narratives
sections take place outside of the open
world and linear environments you can't
return to and once the plot really
starts going at the end the open world
has taken away completely this
highlights a major weak point of open
world game design it's very difficult to
have a traditional large-scale story in
an open world because to make it really
pay off you have to have the world react
and respond to the story and that's a
lot of work so some games will choose to
focus on a series of smaller scale
stories that add up instead which is how
the witcher 3 does it or they decide to
tell their story through other means
entirely like Metal Gear Solid 5 s
collectibles and I good yes I became
obsessed with them I don't deny that
open roles can be downright magical when
done right but because the scale is so
much larger than typical games
developers really need to put in that
much more extra effort to get them right
but even then open world design is not
some seasoning you can just sprinkle on
to any game and make it work you have to
make concessions and I worry about what
these games are losing in these
transitions so instead of putting an
open world into their game because it's
the popular thing that people like I
think developers should ask what are the
benefits of going open world and what
are the drawbacks will this game be fun
to play an open role can we change it to
be fun and keep its identity because
sometimes these changes can take away
from what makes of that series special
in the first place and suddenly it just
looks like everything else